[Música]
as viagens carlos drummond de andrade
o homem bicho da terra tão pequeno
chateia esse fator lugar de muita
miséria pouca diversão constrói um
foguete uma cápsula
o módulo toca pra lua
o homem desce na lua cautelosamente
pisar na lua
anda na lua planta uma bandeirola na lua
experimenta lua economiza lua se visa
lua humaniza nua
normalizada tão igual à terra
vamos pra marte
o homem disse marti experimenta
colonizam civiliza humaniza marte com
jenny art arte humanizado mas julga
quadrado
vamos pra outra parte venus o homem
invisível - e eu visto é isto o item a
item ii tem repetido tório restam ainda
outros sistemas além do solar a
colonizar mas só acabar e estará o homem
e
estará ele que pato
é difícil danger ozzy se na viagem de
fim a si mesmo pisar no chão do seu
coração
descobri a partir de suas próprias
inexploradas entranhas
a pl e insuspeita da alegria de conviver
o bumbum
eu sou o que sou porque nós somos
o doutor eu sou o que sou porque nós
agora a gente então vai convidá los para
uma viagem ao inexplorado de nós mesmos
onzes foram mais outros foram menos
alguns nunca olharam pra lá mas a gente
vai construir junto uma música
vamo eba
obrigada eu vou contar com esse pessoal
desse quadrante tudo bem vocês estarão
comigo posso pedir para vocês levantarem
eba
esse pessoal aqui vai me acompanhar num
ritmo bem simples que é assim ó 1 2 312
312 312 312 indoor olha comigo agora a
gente está desfalcado aí pessoal não tem
que bater forte
o pessoal aí do fundo pode ficar de pé
somos o número 21 23 12 311 313 1
obrigada nós somos o 3
nesse quadrante aqui na frente quem
puder também se levantar porque a
energia fica mais é circular
nós vamos no 3 a fab vai dar um a a
camil 20 nós no 3123 batendo no peito do
estranho a gente vai juntar a isso uma
palavra ubuntu kuo o tudo
o vôo 8102
[Música]
onde tudo é incerto
comprando a harmonia num gesto
[Música]
desenhando a meu tia incerto
encontrando-a a moreninha ponto a ponto
mas de tornar angola
o encontro faz dois nós um sol a sol
ó
[Música]
um sol
ó
o
[Música]
háháhá
o bom tom
agora tem um envelopinho lógica vocês
pegaram o túnel abram ainda a gente vai
descer
nós vamos nos juntar a beleza de uma vez
que a alegria é uma mudança que nos leva
a lugar olhando isso nunca chegará nesse
momento a gente vai junto com muita uma
grande roda de alegria tem muito caminho
do gol
vamos tentar construir uma grande roda
nesse espaço pode ocupar o meio pra que
a gente consegue uma grande corrente que
sim só dar uma olha pra mim lá lerosa
[Música]
olha para as pessoas do lado o outro é o
outro vamos aqui o culto pode fiz seis
não revelar pinho está ok ninguém vai
entrar aqui de volta
antes a gente olhar o envelope
vamos junto o mundo num todo mundo bom
o mundo olha pra quem está do seu lado
um olhar para quem está do lado então
agora vocês podem pegar o envelope
dentro do envelope vai ter pra vocês um
presente um presente que não abram ainda
o presente que vai deixar claro quem é o
maior responsável pelo equilíbrio a
alegria ea convivência de vocês
quando a gente olha pra gente reconhece
nossas precariedades dos nossos sucessos
a gente aceita outro aceita melhor e tem
uma vida mais tranqüila equilibrada
podem olhar o presente olhem com
bastante atenção pra quem é o grande
presente na vida de vocês a palmas pra
vocês
o bumbum voltou o mundo podem aceitar o
ubuntu não esqueça da linha eduardo que
o ubuntu o muito o luto do mundo
obrigada do luto
[Música]